إنه ليس الرجل الذي سيأخذ الكرة 10
أمتار خلف منطقة الجزاء ، سيكون واحدًا
وثلاثة سيحرزون الأهداف وليس
هناك أي إعاقة يجب عليه أن
يعرفك بالكرات التي يتم تسليمها
قدر الإمكان لمن لديه
لاعبين رائعين.  هو وإه ولكن
الهدف الأول بالطبع هو أن
والده والكبد من كيفن
رائعان
، آه نعم
دائمًا ما أؤمن جيدًا بما نعرفه جيدًا ،
فهو يعيش 24 ساعة لمهنته من أجل
وظيفته أود أن أقول شغفك  أو الحب
ليس التوتر كثيرًا
عندما تسير الأمور على ما يرام أو يكون الوضع سيئًا
مستقرًا ،
هذا يشعر بالهزيمة ،
لذلك من الجيد حقًا أن الأرقام لا
تصدق لم أكن أعرف ذلك ولكن هناك
العديد من الأهداف في المباراة الأولى والإياب
كم عدد الآلهة بالفعل  سجل
لذا لكن الحقيقة لا تزال
وراءنا لفترة أطول قليلاً من خلال
أرسنال